do you remember in the 2019 London
Bridge terrorist attack yeah do you
remember when that terrorist tried to
get access to the pub right he had a
knife in his hand yeah exactly M
yeah thanks for number one showing out
my punch line and number two making me
scared for my [__] life
mate but yeah you're right because there
were milw supporters there he said the
words that on milw you can't then hit
him with a
chair because sometimes ladies you need
a
racist going to be honest with you we
never would have lost a war in
Afghanistan if we'd sent over mil wolf
fans we wouldn't would we we would have
brought them over we would have gone
lazza bazer daza shaza
Gaza you see that LW over there mate
yeah you see them that's West Ham off
you
go